on a de nouvelles révélations dans notre
enquête sur des dénonciations de
présumée pédophilie chez les témoins de
jéhovah au québec
il a fait une victime du système mis en
place par les témoins de jéhovah
quand entre les faits la présumée
victime de témoins de jéhovah tente pour
une deuxième fois de convaincre la
police de la prendre au sérieux
ça a été le déclic devant les tableaux
de l'enquêteur il ya deux choses qu'on
pourrait peut-être essayer notre enquête
sur des allégations de pédophilie chez
les témoins de jéhovah a fait grand
bruit l'an dernier et il ya du nouveau
dans ce dossier mais avant de vous faire
part des derniers développements voici
en rappel notre reportage
c'était un homme charmant
un homme qui paraît c'est quand même
bien toujours un bon souvenir toujours
une parole douce c'était la nuit le
faisait noir donc médias j'ai jamais été
dans ce chemin là et arrêter la voiture
et c'est à ce moment là qui m'a demandé
est ce que tu me trouves pas ce qui me
demander si je retrouvais bout le prêt
demandé embrasse moi
[Musique]
et il m'a demandé si j'avais déjà
embrassé quelqu'un je toulon 15 g soit
sa langue
j'ai reculé puis rentrer sa langue dans
ma bouche je me suis dégagé de lui puis
celle qui m'a dit tant par être vraiment
pas content de savoir ce qui se passait
et me dit tu es une grande fille me
ton père serait pas contente de soins 6e
-
c'est vital je devais avoir 11 ans 11
ans et je trouve ça dégueulasse
elles étaient deux mais une seule des
petites filles va s'en tirer
l'histoire de l'autre commence à mont
laurier
[Musique]
quand j'étais plus jeune je pensais que
tout le monde faisait sur dans la
communication qui je cherchais mes temps
à savoir qui faisait quoi avec qui je
pensais que chacun aurait avait avec
quoi maîtresse enfin où je sais pas ce
que c'est la normalité
[Musique]
il s'appelait michel courtemanche
c'était l'ami de la famille le père de
trois enfants
le premier a complimenté pénélope et le
premier dit elle à la toucher je devais
avoir 11 1 sa fille avait pas tout à
fait tonne était sur mes genoux il
semblait me reconduire chez nous puis
mais lui faisait que jeter b il me
caressait encore la poitrine je veux
vraiment mal figé
j'ai regardé ça fait comme si ce système
grave devant elle
puis me dis c'est pas grave à part le
haut
[Musique]
toutes les semaines michel courtemanche
et son épouse enseigne les principes de
la bible à de futurs témoins de jéhovah
pénélope garde de leurs enfants
si la routine du lundi et puis quand y
revenir de cette étude l'eau il envoyait
sa femme soit allé chercher du
restaurant ou louer un film puis
venaient m'agresser dans la chambre je
refusais toujours mettre ma main sur son
pénis et de prendre erreur son pénis
dans ma bouche toujours
elle a 14 ans lors de la première
relation sexuelle complète
ce sera la première d'une longue série
qu'elle aurait subis et ce même si sa
famille a déménagé à 4h de mont laurier
et venaient visiter mes parrains pour
dire bonjour puis resté pour la nuit à
coucher et ses nuits là il ne me
rejoindre dans ma chambre
elle en parle de viol complet des
nuitées
[Musique]
pénélope ne sait pas qu'elle peut dire
non c'est en parcourant un article du
magazine des témoins de jéhovah qu elle
le réalise
je lis lui et j'ai compris que ce que je
vivais ça lève le mot se lavait le nom à
l'épaule g7 en la calle venue garder les
enfants et a essayé de rentrer ses mains
en dessous de mon slip c'est là que j'ai
poussé ma vie que j'ai dit savoir faire
que c'est terminé
presque tout de suite elle révèle son
secret ses parents sont atterrés et en
bons témoins de jéhovah il alerte les
dirigeants de leur congrégation
leur but faire exclure michel
courtemanche des témoins est ce qu'ils
cherchent constamment j'ai été exclu à
cette époque là non et est-ce que vous
avez été exclu oui j'ai été exclu pour
quelle raison parce que j'avais un job
j'étais pas mariés pour que michel
courtemanche puisse être expulsé lui
aussi il aurait au moins fallu un témoin
oculaire ou une autre plaignante
c'est obligatoire dans le système de
justice interne des témoins de jéhovah
ce qui est aussi obligatoire c'est de
recueillir la version de la victime
alléguée ce que personne n'aurait fait
ma question c'est est pourquoi vous
n'avez jamais voulu savoir ce qui
m'était arrivé pourquoi vous m'avez
jamais questionné puis pourquoi vous
avez rien faire qu'est ce qui a été fait
c'est une bonne question à poser aux
témoins de jéhovah mais aussi à la
sûreté municipale de mont laurier
car pénélope se tourner vers la police
en 1995 il a fallu que je parte avec mon
petit courage allez rencontrer un
policier que je connais c'est pour qui
finalement qui était pas formés non plus
à me recevoir
c'est le patrouilleur jean-pierre
gaudemer qui l'accueille au poste mais
le ch qui est à l'ultime tatum invs
avait été violent
aussi ce qui reste du dossier de police
outre la déclaration de pénélope
il ne contient rien
le policier n'a rencontré aucun témoin
potentiel dans la famille ou la
congrégation de pénélope ces milieux ce
que l'inflation
c'est quand même yann je sais ferment
puis quoi que ce soit que ses collègues
programme est qu il ya le saut dans le
milieu là dessus il n'a peut être pas
tout à fait tort les témoins de jéhovah
ne dénonce une possible agression
d'enfants que si la loi les y oblige
ce tableau réalisé par les témoins eux
même exposé toutes les étapes de leur
système de justice religieuse
quant au chemin vers la justice laïque
il est pour le moins tortueux jusqu'à 13
étapes avant d'alerter les autorités et
jusqu'à 30 étapes à franchir avant de
fournir des documents à la justice
mais le but ultime c'est de s'arrêter à
l'étape 24 et de maintenir le secret je
regarde ça et il ya quelque chose qui me
vient à l'esprit la maison des fous
c'est incroyable comment une victime
peut passer à travers
autant d'étapes pour à la fin très
souvent avoir aucune reconnaissance de
ce qui s'est passé
marilou lagacé a grandi chez les témoins
avant de quitter de son plein gré depuis
elle tente de comprendre et de
déconstruire leur justice parallèle
quand on étudie le processus
on réalise vraiment que cissé c'est
plutôt un processus d'évitement c'est
plutôt un système de protection de la
réputation des témoins de jéhovah
protéger la réputation des témoins de
jéhovah c'est exactement ce que les
témoins de mont-laurier aurait demandé
aux parents de pénélope
il y a vingt ans bayon appelé mes
parents nous ont mis la pression pour
qu'ils essaient de me décourager mais
dissuader il voulait que je retire ma
plainte mais penelope persiste et en
novembre 96
le procès de michel courtemanche débute
à mont laurier
j'étais tout seul seul son seul mais
j'étais seul aussi parce que les témoins
de jéhovah avait interdit à tout le
monde d'aller
selon nos informations lors du procès
michel courtemanche j'aurais insisté sur
le fait que pénélope avec 14 ans l'âge
du consentement à l'époque il a toujours
nié avoir eu des relations sexuelles
complètes avec elle pénélope n'a ni
témoin ni preuve des agressions qui
seraient survenus avant et après 14 ans
d'après moi
à cette époque là oui j'avais fait tout
ce que j'avais pu avec les moyens que
j'avais le plus de connaissances que
j'avais j'avais fait tout ce que je
pouvais
le 19 décembre 1996 michel courtemanche
est déclaré non coupable il ne reste
aucune trace des motifs du jugement ni
les témoignages lors du procès
au début des années 80 avant l'histoire
de pénélope michel courtemanche habite à
mont laurier
mais il travaille à terrebonne la
semaine je me rappelle on a vu un trou
télévision en bois d'un salon une chaîne
et arsenal dans les hit boy en avant ils
gardent parfois les enfants de son
patron un soir il demande à carole
poudrier dix ans de s'asseoir près de
lui il se serait mis à la chatouiller et
à la caresser
elle s'enfuit dans sa chambre et c'est
là qu'il a rejoint il s'est accroupi
timothy c'est faux drapeau cultive parce
que ton part il serait pas content c'est
pas des rangs d'une grande fille
maintenant qu'ils seraient pas contents
que ce soit c'est sur moi mais je digère
et pau elle tient parole
quelques mois plus tard michel
courtemanche lui aurait demandé de
l'embrasser une première fois puis une
seconde je peux pas croire que sa salive
sa langue avait rentré dans ma bouche et
j'étais j'ai eu un dégoût tellement
total que gg je me suis dégagé de lui je
me servirai barjac
cette fois-ci carole parlera à une amie
plus vieille qui fera son devoir de
témoins de jéhovah et dénoncera michel
courtemanche aux dirigeants la semaine
suivante un ancien de la congrégation se
présente à la maison familiale
j'étais vraiment stressé de parler d'une
sorte de sexualité avec un monsieur que
je connais pas devant mon père
oh mon dieu c'était gênant mais il m'a
demandé ce qui s'était passé alors je
lui ai dit et il me remercie me dit
qu'ils étaient pour s'occuper de ça cet
ancien selon carole c'est john mcewen
qui a depuis gravi les échelons jusqu'au
quartier général des témoins à toronto
dans une lettre que nous avons obtenus
john kirwan admet connaître carole et sa
famille mais il nous avoir discuté avec
eux des gestes de reprocher à michel
courtemanche voyons dans le temps c'est
impossible c'est un film mais pas chez
moi dans mon sous-sol avec mon père et
par là mon père j'étais là j'étais assis
à terre aux autres et à 6 sur 10 20 je
m'entends au après tout était correct ne
peut pas dire qu'il ne pourra compris
le père de carole poudrier ou confirme
avoir discuté du cas de michel
courtemanche avec les anciens de
terrebonne il dit avoir pardonné à son
employé qui a continué de travailler
pour lui un certain temps
est il possible que les témoins de
terrebonne n'ait pas averti leurs frères
de mont-laurier de la présence d'un
agresseur potentiel dans leurs
congrégations impossible et ça jamais
très ma main au feu surtout pour quelque
chose comme ce nom c'est impossible
la première chose qu'ils doivent faire
c'est on prend le téléphone on appelle
sa création en lisant ton membre de ta
cambiasso y est chez nous puis voici ce
qu'il fait depuis presque 40 ans toutes
les politiques des témoins disent la
même chose dans une situation comme
celle là une congrégation doit en
avertir une autre des allégations de
péché grave commis par ses membres
puisque me choque hautement je faisais
pas partie de la congrégation terrebonne
c'est sûr qu'ils ont avisé la
congrégation mont laurier
parce que c'est une patate chaude à
terrebonne qui n'a pas fait sa part dans
ce dossier là les adultes les adultes
les anciens parce que dans
l'organisation des témoins de jéhovah ya
jamais un seul homme qui est au courant
[Musique]
si l'information sur michel courtemanche
a été transmise aux anciens et de mont
laurier
les parents de cette congrégation ne
l'ont jamais su c'était en 1983
environ un an avant que ne débute
histoire de penne là
[Musique]
après la pause pénélope confronte les
témoins de jéhovah ce qui m'est arrivé à
12 ans a touché au sein faire de son
chandail dans sa voiture raison il vient
me rejoindre les membres à mettre au
pénis dans ma pour l'histoire de ville
et la baie est très particulière parce
que à toutes les fois qu'il essaie de
faire un cheminement à ses passes est
toujours fermée ce fait fermé la porte
j'avais pas eu le dernier mot j'avais
pas pu m'expliquer comme fo devant des
bonnes personnes compétentes
ça devient difficile de se débattre de
se défendre de toute façon on n'apprend
pas à se défendre chez les témoins de
jéhovah on apprend à tourner et l'autre
joue pour recevoir le clac en 2014
pénélope fait une rencontre déterminante
avec l'ex témoins marilou lagacé elle
décide de relancer les protagonistes de
son histoire par lettre qu'il a envoyée
aux cinq anciens qui m'ont exclu à
l'époque et je les envoyer au siège
social est à mon agresseur
je voulais dire que c'était terminé que
j'aimais je me tairai
[Musique]
c'est une première étape et cette fois
ci les anciens réagissent rapidement le
vendredi soir j'avais deux anciens qui
m'appelait pour me dire qu'ils avaient
bien reçu ma lettre mais qui comprenait
pas ma question c'est quoi votre
question ma question c'est est pourquoi
vous n'avez jamais voulu savoir ce qui
m'était arrivé limon dit on n'a pas
besoin
on n'a pas eu besoin de s'en occuper
georges l'éclat y est allé te rencontrer
chez vous pour prendre sa déposition
georges leclercq était président de la
congrégation de mont laurier il y avait
25 ans lorsque pénélope a révélé son
secret et qu'est-ce que vous avez réagi
mais j'ai du cths était jamais arrivé
est jamais venu me rencontrer les
parents de pénélope le confirme georges
leclercq n'a jamais recueilli leur
version ni celle de leur fille
mais là j'ai senti que vraiment il y
avait quelque chose qui était encore
plus grave plus louche je me suis dit oh
si c'était pour protéger son ami à qui
son ami son ami c'était mon agresseur
michel courtin michel courtemanche
georges leclercq était effectivement un
des meilleurs amis de michel
courtemanche
il dirigeait la congrégation dans les
années 80 la période où penelope aurait
été abusée à mont laurier et carole
poudrier à terrebonne les deux par
michel courtemanche les reds est exclu
il rêve être imprimant dès après ces
actes à moi et ils résultent exclu après
les actes de pénurie
mais courtemanche n'a pas été exclue des
témoins de jéhovah à l'époque
bonjour pourquoi l'ex dirigeant georges
leclercq refuse de répondre aux
questions
[Musique]
en 2015 pénélope veut des réponses car
depuis longtemps des bruits courent
elles ne seraient ni la seule ni la
première que courtemanche aurait touché
mais elle ne connaît pas carole poudrier
qui de son côté ignorent l'existence
même de pénélope
jusqu'au jour où carroll raconte son
histoire à une vieille amie qui connaît
bien mont-laurier quand on m'a dit que
sa soeur habite à mont-laurier jeudi
enrichi si je connais quelqu'un qui est
qu'ils savaient déjà essayé sur moi à
l'époque il me gardais pia vais essayer
de de m'embrasser puis de me toucher
et je lui nommé le nom michel
courtemanche le soir même la confidente
de carole répète le nom michel
courtemanche a sa propre copine une
certaine marie lou lagacé vous pouvez
vous imaginer ma réaction à cette soirée
là j'apprends qui a une autre victime
que peiné là je connais large de carole
poudrier je connais large de pénélope et
là je comprends que bien que carole
s'est fait agresser avant pinellas et
j'écris à pénélope sont souvent là est
ce que tu connais une carole poudrier
mais c'était surréaliste
j'aurais même pas cru que ça aurait pu
arriver je recevais les textos et en
direct restaurant où elle était et puis
j'en revenais pas c'était c'était un
cadeau elle s'était enfin trouvé et
c'est chez carole qu'elles ont pu
comparer tous cas me racontait je voyais
des les mêmes paroles
joyet le même personnage va ressembler
votre histoire beaucoup mais en même
temps ça semble
elle a eu la brillante idée de leur
poussée elle était forte
[Musique]
ce soit qui fait la différence
une femme de mon âge mais j'ai vu une
petite fille aussi ça m'a vraiment
faibles ça me fait beaucoup de peine
pour eux on était deux matin on était le
témoin m de l'autre carole est devenu ma
vérité sur le monstre et là on a compris
que les autorités religieuses savez pour
carole puisqu'elle en a parlé et puis
elle a rencontré des anciens mais en
fait on a compris que leur processus à
ce moment là avait effectivement protégé
un pédophile
ce qui est certain c'est que vingt ans
auparavant ni la police ni le procureur
et encore moins le juge du procès de
michel courtemanche ne connaissait
l'existence d'une première victime
potentielle
carole poudrier aurait-elle pu faire
pencher la balance du procès en faveur
de pénélope le sicom pose une question à
cent mille dollars
la juge à la retraite céline lamontagne
a examiné pour nous les récits des deux
victimes
alors donc de ce que j'ai lu du dossier
les faits similaires première mais l'aja
victimes la nature des gestes sexuels
poser les baisers la fal l'évolution des
attouchements dans les deux cas c'était
similaires ensuite il y avait les
paroles qui ont été prononcées qui sont
importants qui sont les mêmes paroles
ont été prononcées exactement dans l'est
dans les deux cas la juge lamontagne ne
souhaite pas refaire le procès et elle
rappelle qu'une preuve de faits
similaires n'est pas toujours admise en
cours mais lorsqu'elle est admise
elle peut théoriquement faire une
différence
c'est sûr que la preuve des faits
similaires admise vient ajouter du poids
à la version de la première victime
et ça rend plus probant le fait que oui
c'est pour ces quelque chose oui est-ce
que je suis convaincu hors de tout doute
raisonnable
mais j'ai une preuve 1 et 2
c'est une évaluation que la justice n'a
pas pu faire dans ce cas ci les témoins
de jéhovah n'ayant jamais révélé à la
police
l'existence d'une première victime si le
juge lui avait demandé d'expliquer ce
que vous avez subi lorsque vous aviez
dix ans au moment du procès
l'auriez-vous fait à 100 % à 100 %
après avoir envoyé sa lettre en 2014
pénélope est prête pour la seconde étape
la rencontre avec de hauts placés des
témoins de jéhovah qu'elle décide
d'enregistrer
elle a beaucoup de questions ils ont
plus de réponse jusqu'à ce que pénélope
demande des nouvelles de georges
leclercq
l'ancien dirigeant de la congrégation de
mont laurier la réponse des anciens lui
glace le sang vous avez bien compris
georges leclercq l'ancien dirigeant de
la congrégation de mont-laurier ce
georges leclercq aurait perdu son titre
d'ancien et ses privilèges de témoins de
jéhovah pour cause de pédophilie
nous avons parlé à trois femmes qui ont
porté plainte contre lui aux témoins de
jéhovah et nous ont raconté leur
histoire mais ont refusé de le faire
devant la caméra
comment avait réagi quand tu es voulions
confirmer c'est ce que j'ai trouvé de
perge pas depuis au moins 20 ans tout
incident d'abus d'enfants rapporté à
l'interné chez les témoins doit être
envoyées au quartier général de chaque
pays
aux etats unis l'accès à cette liste de
pédophile fait l'objet d'une bataille
épique entre les avocats des victimes et
ceux des témoins de jéhovah la lettre de
pénélope michel courtemanche l'a reçu
lui aussi en 2014
ils téléphonent aux parents de pénélope
et finit par se mettre à table
may à vous et à vous et beaucoup
beaucoup de choses et avoue que c'est
lui qui menait me rejoignent ya voué à
ma mère qui avait mis son pénis dans la
bouche mais je peux vous lui ai avoué le
viol mais est ce que michel courtemanche
vous appelez vous jamais nous avons
rejoint michel courtemanche au téléphone
il a refusé de nous rencontrer et a tout
nié en bloc
il nous a affirmé avoir commis une
erreur celle de s'être retrouvé seul
avec pénélope à toutes les autres
questions sur des gestes sexuels commis
sur une mineure
il a déclaré ceci avait fait qu'il y ait
ici
et puis jugement que j'ai bac
michel courtemanche ne fait plus partie
des témoins de jéhovah
il a été exclu il y a trois ans à la
suite de la lettre de pénélope et de la
dénonciation de deux autres femmes
[Musique]
certaines choses ont changé depuis cette
époque aujourd'hui les témoins de
jéhovah affirme avertir certains parents
de la présence d'un pédophile notoire
dans leur congrégation
ce n'est pas suffisant croix carole
poudrier mon frère qui est ancien je
demandais à mon frère je dis s'il ya des
enfants qui sont victimes de pédophilie
dans votre congrégation qu'est ce que
vous faites ce que vous faites des
discours pour leur dire personne le
droit de vous toucher ce que vous faites
sur les mains dit non le changement chez
les témoins de jéhovah pénélope n'y
croit plus sa quête de justice se
poursuivra ailleurs elle vient de
déposer une nouvelle plainte à la police
la sûreté du québec de mont laurier a
rouvert l'enquète qui prend de l'ampleur
aujourd'hui au moment où l'on se parle
on est à près d'une quarantaine de
personnes qui ont été rencontrés
oui des témoins mais également des
victimes on est en mesure d'établir qui
pourrait y avoir sept victimes
potentielles dont quatre ont
officiellement porté plainte contre
michel courtemanche ou georges leclercq
et les enquêteurs de la sûreté tendent
l'oreille on cherche identifier d'autres
victimes potentielles qui se sentent
peut-être seul pas prête à parler ils
doivent savoir que les encadrants sont
prêts à les rencontrer également des
témoins qu'il y ait des les gens c'est
sûr qu'ils connaissent des choses
au retour pénélope se souvient d'un
événement qui deviendra la clé de
l'enquète policière 24 ans plus tard
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la police débuté son enquête lorsque
nous vous avons présenté ce reportage
pour la première fois et vous allez voir
qu'il ya eu des développements
importants à la suite des démarches de
pénélope
[Musique]
un an et demi plus tard pénélope est de
retour à mont laurier et c'est mon
village
c'est ici que j'ai grandi
c'est ici que j'ai été exclu des témoins
de jéhovah c'est quand même
de refaire ce chemin
basso qui a cédé à la halle qui est un
gie qui traînait sur toute ma vie tant
on parle de 24 ans le plus tard se
stresser pour demain je parle de voix
j'ai plus mal de voir ce qui va décider
pénélope a rendez vous demain à mont
laurier un rendez vous important pour
l'accompagner celle qui lui a redonné sa
vérité la deuxième victime présumée
carole poudrier avoir une agression
comme ça que ce soit personnel ou pour
d'autres voies que sa marque la vie
cette web en direct tous passent
moi je sens que tout ce passe bien
paul passion à l'étoile
c'est au printemps 2017 que pénélope a
déposé sa deuxième plainte contre michel
courtemanche et carole poudrier sa
première cette fois ci les policiers
prennent la situation au sérieux
commence alors une enquête exhaustive
sur michel courtemanche et son ami
georges leclercq 47 personnes sont
rencontrés sur presque un an
en fait perdre quelque chose de gros
c'est pas c'est pas une cause
personnelle c'est pour faire avancer
quelque chose de plus gros quelque chose
de plus groupe comme la vague de fond du
mouvement - aussi qui déferle sur le
québec et la planète presqu'en même
temps on sait qu'on va être portée qu'on
n'est plus tout seul je t'aime je suis
vraiment tout seul et plein de monde pis
on est là pour d'autres les autres s'y
sont le porno aux mails enquête sur les
cinq autres victimes présumées de michel
courtemanche et georges leclercq n'a pas
débouché sur des accusations
nous avons parlé à plusieurs de ces
femmes qui nous ont révélé ne pas
vouloir témoigner pour des raisons
religieuses
ils comprennent que s'ils vont de
l'avant avec des accès à 106
ils vont l'avant avec un processus
judiciaire eelv ont entaché la
réputation l'étaiement john carroll et
pénélope
elles ont gardé le cap est maintenu leur
plainte mais pour les policiers le cas
de pénélope est très complexe car michel
courtemanche avait déjà été jugé et
acquitté vingt ans auparavant au poste
de police
quand on a compris on peut pas parler de
tout ce qui c'était passé à montlaur et
pourquoi parce qu'ils avaient été jugés
non coupables
pour tout seul c'est un obstacle majeur
michel courtemanche je ne pourra pas
être accusé des mêmes crimes
une seconde fois la première fois qu
installer au poste de police que j'ai
rencontré un monsieur gall maire j'avais
aucune idée qu'est-ce que c'était une
déclaration
j'avais aussi découvrir j'avais même
pour les grandes lignes écrites
pénélope doit donc refaire ses devoirs
avec l'aide de son amie marie lou avant
d'aller rencontrer les policiers au puy
mary lou on avait fait la chronologie
j'avais écrit aussi des notes publiées
qui fait sauter
écosociété et en effet que ce travail le
savourer un bon quatre heures que j'ai
dit oui et ça je me souviens de tout ça
et on le tout mis en chronologie
parfaitement avec toutes les incidents
donc là quand on regarde les choses
accusations qui ont été portées
le mauvais temps et le jeu réalise que
des deux agressions qui faisait pas
partie des chefs d'accusation et avait
été fait parce que vous ne l'aviez pas
mentionné quand vous aviez 20 ans
exactement
un oubli une simple omission qui
deviendra la clé de la nouvelle enquête
policière 24 ans plus tard l'heure j'ai
posé la question à laon quatre
enquêteurs du vélo il ya deux agressions
qui se sont passés à d'autres endroits
dans des villes différentes est ce que
ça pourrait s'appeler faire quelque
chose d'assez ses yeux en lui mais et et
l'oeil a dit ben ça c'est des nouvelles
accusations l'heure on s'est regardé et
penelope mois pour neuf et sommes donc
ça a été le déclic devant les tableaux
de l'enquêteur acquis il ya deux choses
qu'on pourrait peut-être essayer et à
l'été 2010 est pénélope se retrouve à
nouveau dans le bureau d'un enquêteur de
la sûreté du québec de mont laurier
elle est prête pour sa deuxième chance
enfin sexuelle courte à manches pour
dénoncer deux agressions qu'elle fait
sur moi ou écoutent allait passer la
journée à l'avant qui le sort de la
bouche et dans un appartement à montréal
cet été la pénélope avait 13 ans dans la
nuit sur la maille des couteliers chacun
1000 tonnes de jouets les chemises les
mannequins russes et les femmes ok on
n'a que sa femme était couché à côté
hockey qui y pénétrer ses doigts dans ma
vie j'avais tellement pas que d'une
famille lacoste y avait d'autres soldats
lamine guissé mon plus grand stress
ok j'étais plus stressée oui paris puis
je comprends pas ok ok je comprenne ce
qu'est du monde autour de toi
l'exercice est pénible mais aux yeux de
pénélope beaucoup plus utile que sa
première expérience avec la police dans
les années 90
quant à carole les seuls à avoir entendu
son histoire sont les dirigeants des
témoins lorsqu'elle avait 11 ans pour
elle le contraste avec les méthodes de
la police est encore plus clair c'est
documenté stega régal je sentais qu'ils
avaient pas de jugement mais quand je
parlais aux témoins de jéhovah j'étais
assis à terre
y'avait pas d'écrit j'étais une enfant
qui avait l'impression d'avoir fait
quelque chose demain
finalement les efforts de tous ont porté
fruit après un an et demi dans quête
michel courtemanche est accusé d'avoir
agressé sexuellement
pénélope herbert et carole poudrier dans
les années 80
[Musique]
le soir du 9 décembre elle se rendait à
mont laurier pour voir michel
courtemanche enregistré son plaidoyer le
lendemain au palais de justice
je veux voir si nous parlons je veux
voir voyons donc s qui il veut dire
qu'il est devant tout le monde que c'est
faux que j'aime le hockey que c'est pas
vrai que c'est pas arrivé je peux pas
concevoir qu'on va être capable de dire
ouf ça dans ma pièce de moi ça se peut
pas il ne lui aura pas fait ce cadeau
le lendemain c'est une avocate qui a
représenté michel courtemanche
il ne s'est pas présenté au tribunal
rejoint au téléphone il affirme n'être
au courant de rien je vous rappelle en
fait parce que des développements dans
votre situation si je comprends bien le
aucune idée vous savez pas vous avez
utilisé d'agression sexuelle entre deux
victimes partout aucune idée vous avez
marre de tes une avocate pour vous
représenter à mont laurier en décembre
donc je vous êtes au courant
en attendant un éventuel plaidoyer
pénélope aura de quoi s'occuper
elle est l'une des plaignantes de la
demande de recours collectif des
victimes d'abus sexuels contre
l'organisation des témoins de jéhovah
pénélope est une victime du système mis
en place par les témoins de jéhovah chez
vous protéger des pédophiles
on est le premier pays dans le monde qui
se lancent dans cette cette grande
aventure
c'est pas gagné d'avancé sont des très
très beau à voir
les gouvernements commencent à se
réveiller et à mettre le nez là dedans
de façon très sérieuse ton et comme aux
premières loges de tout ça c'est un beau
début l'eau parce qu'après ça je me
joindrai ça va faire boule de neige
à force de faire un écho une voie qui va
se faire entendre
puis la justice va finir par trouver son
chemin
[Musique]